I'm trying. It's hard when I see the
headlines like, "Oh my goodness." Here,
here's what God says to his people.
Isaiah 12:14, "You are not to say it is
a conspiracy in regard to all that this
people call a conspiracy." See what he
says? Don't follow the party line, the
status quo. Don't get sucked up into the
height and become a conspiracy theorist.
You are not to fear what they fear, and
you shall not tremble. Don't panic and
freak out like those who don't know that
Jesus is alive, who reigns, he's
almighty, and he'll preserve his church.
In fact, some of you are so carried away
with the conspiracy, you're turning a
blind eye to the Christians right now
who are getting
in Sudan, women getting in and Nigeria
getting
you think they're worried about your
conspiracy theory. They're already in
tribulation.
They are already in tribulation.
And you're not to fear what they fear.
and you shall not tremble. It is Yahweh
of host whom you should regard as holy,
meaning set it apart in your heart and
mind. Be immovable, unshakable, and this
resolve and conviction. Yahweh is
almighty. He reigns over the nations.
He will be triumphant.
You fear him and his judgment and he
shall be your cause of trembling. Then
he shall be a sanctu. He will be your
protection, your safe haven, your city
of refuge.
Right?
What do they call those states that are
refuge for illegals?
refuge for illegals? There's a term for,
right?
I forgot the term
to use a modern term.
Sanctuary cities. You know where they
got it from? Sanctuary cities. Sanctuary
states. They got it from your Bible,
dude. He is your sanctuary state. He's
your sanctuary city. I will be your safe
haven, your sanctuary.
See that?
They got it from the Bible.
So why you panicking? Why you freaking
out? What? Jesus is dead or is he alive?
Is he almighty?
I know. Well, brother, what can you
really do? You do what you need to do to
protect your family, but can you really
do much? How you going to overthrow the
problem?
You need a new regime.
But to both the house of Israel, a stone
to strike and a rock to stumble over and
a snare and a trap for inhabitants of
Jerusalem. Now, this is Old Testament,
right? Well, guess what Peter does?
Peter quotes this and applies it for the
spiritual Israel of Christ. Peter now
will quote Isaiah 8 and apply it to you
spiritual Israel. See what God had told
Israel. He's telling you the church, his
new Israel, the same thing. You the
church. 1 Peter 3 14- 16. But even if
you have you should suffer for the sake
of righteousness, you are blessed. Do
not fear their fear and do not be
troubled. He's alluding to Isaiah
8:12-13.
But sanctify, set apart in your hearts
and minds. Be unshakable, immovable in
his conviction. Christ is Lord.
Have no doubt he's risen. He's almighty.
He's alive. Ironically, Peter just took
Isaiah 8 where it says, "Sanctify, set
apart Yahweh
in your hearts and minds and he applied
it to Christ." He's saying, you know who
that Yahweh is that you are fixated on
and hope in who's your sanctuary? Christ
Jesus. See what he did?
See what he did?
Christ is that Yahweh that you be
fixated on, focus on, hope in
knowing he's almighty, and at the end
you win. Always being ready to make a
defense to everyone who asks you to give
an account for the hope that is with you
with Gentiles fear. Meaning, you're
being persecuted because you renounce
idolatry.
You stop going to the temples and
sacrificing to the gods and goddesses
and you're being imprisoned and tortured
if not killed or left homeless because
you now view Christ as Lord and not
Caesar as Lord. You believe Christ is
God, not Zeus. And you Jews, you're
being persecuted because you're taking
this Jew as Lord, as Yahweh.
Now be ready to give an explanation
defense why him and not Zeus
whoever asks
having a good conscience so that in the
thing in which you are slandered what
are they slandering for you slandering
you for a look you're worshiping a dead
Jew a crucified man
you gave up the gods of your ancestors
for a Jew who's not even among your own
race how stupid are Those who disparage
your good con Christ will be put to
shame.
Okay, we got it now.
You understand? Don't be extreme.
It's all about Christ, focusing on
Christ, making Christ famous and known,
praising and glorifying him. When you
spend the majority of your time on
Zionism and Israel's control and its
tentacles in the media, all facts, who
will be edified, who will be
strengthened, who will be at peace, who
will experience
rest
from all of that? Nobody. All you're
going to do is cause more bitterness,
hatred, animosity, and more division.
And no one walks away edified. Nobody.
Nobody.
When are you edified, brothers? When you
hear how beautiful Jesus is. When are
you edified? When blasphemies against
Jesus are destroyed, demolished,
obliterated.
When are you edified? When you see how
miraculous the Bible is, how real God
is.
Right?
That's when you're edified. Isn't that
the case? There is a time to call things
out. Remember Ecclesiastes, the wisdom.
There's a time to call things out. You
can't just completely not because even
the Bible will call out people by name
and their agenda. But some people are
fixated on the conspiracy. They have no
joy, no peace. And you know who I'm
talking about. Some of you who are like
that, you could not function. You were
paranoid. And people didn't like to be
around you because like, what's up with
this guy, man?
Have you been around these conspiracy
nuts? They're constantly paranoid,
constantly second-guessing, and they
cause you to panic where you said, "Man,
I can't deal with this. I'm out of
here." Right.
Right. Yeah, you know what I'm talking
about.
You know what I'm talking about.
That happened to me in the 90s, man. And
the guy's still my friend, but thank God
he's a little civil now. Controlled. He
gave me audio cassette tapes on the
Illuminati, Build-a-Bers, right? Weiss
hop, right? Federal Reserves Act. The
bankers left me paranoid as hell until
God reigned me in and brought me to my
senses.
You may not be paranoid, but if that's
all you're talking about is conspiracy
theories, don't be surprised why you
don't have too many friends around you.
Yeah, Nasha, he he left me paranoid. N
is a Syrian. He doesn't know where
Caldian yet. Okay. He left me paranoid.
Let me tell you how much paranoid I
became. I suspected that the Assyrian
pastor was a plant from the Illuminati
because he was sent by England to be a
preacher to infiltrate the Assyrians.
That's how paranoid he got me.
Did you know that, Miss Anna? I swear to
you, I started drilling him. Uh, so
where were you born? Oh, in Syria. Where
did you go learn theology? In England.
Why did you go to England? Oh, because
they're a missionary. So they chose you
and took you to England and that's where
you got your education. I started
drilling him.
And then he tell me, "Hey, when you go
out,
he would tell me, hey, when you go out,
don't drink anything that's given to
you." He would say in
say I'm speaking Syrian, whatever they
put in front of you, don't take. You
don't know what they put in your drink.
Okay.
Yeah. No, no. I was my my life is what
Listen, brother, if I I think if they
were to make a movie about my life, it
would be
a tragic comedy. It would be one of the
greatest comedies and tragedies ever
known. If they were to make a movie
about my life, the things I've seen, the
things I've done, the things
experienced, it would be probably a box
office hit because it'd be a tragic
comedy.
You would laugh till you cry and you
would cry. What the hell I've seen,
right? Paranoid, you know. How do you
say like Tony Montana said, "How do you
say paranoid?" You know, paranoid. You
know what I'm saying?
Yeah. But brother, you know why? because
they're not fixated on Christ.
Let me end it with this so we can go
into the topic. Just a reminder of you
guys who are paranoid. You want to say
yourself paranoid? You know who cannot
rest? You know who's constantly
paranoid? The wicked, the evil, the
righteous,
persecutors, meaning those who persecute
the righteous, those who oppress the
righteous, those who oppress the
downtrodden, the weak, the alien. They
are the ones paranoid. You know why?
Because God says they'll never be at
peace. Here you go. Let me show it to
you. You ready? And we begin.
Those who persecuted the righteous, the
righteous persecutors, the ones who
persecute the righteous, not that
they're righteous and persecuting.
Persecute the righteous. Oppress the
widow, the orphan, the poor. Take
advantage of them. Here it is. Isaiah
48:22.
There is no peace for the wicked, says
Yahweh.
There is no peace for the wicked,
says Yahweh.
See that?
He repeats it again. Isaiah 48:22.
And he repeats it again. Isaiah 57:21.
There is no peace, says my God, for the
wicked.
wicked. There is no peace, says my God,
for the wicked. Proverbs 28:1.
The wicked flee.
Watch here. Listen. Don't get
distracted. We'll check it out. When
there is no one pursuing,
but the righteous are secure as a lion.
Did you hear? Who is paranoid?
Who freaks out? See, now you see that.
Yeah, we had a great time destroying
anti-trinarian, especially one heretic
in particular on the term firstborn.
Wow. But now watch guys, watch here. The
wicked flee when there's no one
pursuing. But the righteous are secure
as a lion. So who is paranoid? Who has
no rest? The wicked. Then why if you're
righteous and fixated on Christ,
why if you are righteous and fixated in
Christ are you paranoid?
So who's paranoid? Who freaks out? The
wicked. Who has no peace? The wicked. So
if you're righteous and in Christ, why
are you paranoid?
Are you paranoid?
Ecclesiastes 3:18. There's an appointed
time for everything. And there's a time
for every matter under heaven. A time to
give birth and a time to die. See,
there's a time to call things out. But
you have to have balance. A time to
plant and a time to uproot what is
planted. A time to kill and a time to
heal. A time to tear down and a time to
build up.
A time to weep and a time to laugh. A
time to mourn and a time to dance.
A time to throw stones and a time to
gather stones. Time to embrace and a
time to shun embracing. A time to search
and a time to lose.
It's gone. A time to keep, a time to
throw away. A time to tear apart, a time
to sew together. A time to be silent, a
time to be speak. It's to speak right
here. A time to love and a time to hate.
A time for war and a time for peace.
They even made a song out of this. for
every turn.